hello and welcome to new world review i
am grand line waifu and i'm here to give
you a thorough and well balanced review
[Laughter]
just like leorio i can't even get
through that without saying
i am capable of fair and balanced
reviews but these are my thoughts
largely unedited with deep thoughts that
sound really stupid and really light
thoughts that are actually quite deep
like how much anxiety farmboy must have
experienced at finally leaving home for
the first time in literal years
you might not think it but that my
friends is the thought of a deep
thinker which i am ignore that liam in
the corner who likes to troll
you know what we can just vacuum him up
in a monster vacuum of death and he
won't be able to troll me anymore right
right anyway spoilers ahead episode 42
korapika's ark or at least his mini arc
we're focused on him at the moment
opening the episode with kurapaka is
such a great way to remind us
after our week away of exactly what
we're about to experience
at the end of last episode we had drawn
everyone together or we were drawing
everyone together and i'll be honest i
was a little concerned we wouldn't get
any solid direction in terms of what to
look at but the episode was really
nicely organized it was easier to jump
between
all the different elements of what seems
to be coming together now and it was
interesting to see things happening and
the way they brought them together let's
get into it a bit more
finally we see our paole audio who's
acting oddly a little
older than i remember yeah knowing he is
a teenager i still get a sense of
maturity from him
all those phone options and the decision
to buy one that looks like a beetle i
love
seeing tech as a sidebar i love seeing
tech
work in this show because you can so
easily see where they thought technology
was going at the time it's like a
time capsule of thought and technology
i i tried to sound clever did i miss
something
did leyorio spend time with someone who
has a completely different laugh
oh
what is that i can do that too
he's only learned 10 and honestly i'm
impressed that someone studying medicine
could even have got that far in his
learning
so actually he's very intelligent kilo
are thinking leorio is an enhancer
because
well maka i appreciated that callback to
hisoka's way of telling who fits what
style of
ren and so we jump from leorio and his
money-making schemes which honestly i
should have expected to farmboy doing a
really good impression of me stress
eating while i try to write my doctorate
it's an awkward situation because
literally 24 hours ago i was explaining
to liam how i
reached for a bag of popcorn and
shoveled it into my mouth and it
looked this maybe i am farm boy indeed
it does feel as though i was 10 the last
time i was outside so to be directly
called out in this economy seems unfair
given what we know of piggy and greed
island of course he wouldn't be able to
hack it it's designed for hunters
poor guy can't catch a break i would
have been quite interested to see
him have to go through stress because
he's leaving the house for the first
time since he was 10 and that's
intense and could have taken more of a
moment than it got
jumping back to kilwa see we do a lot of
jumping around in this episode why
didn't he think to say earlier that it
would take a really long time for them
to gather the money they needed
actually it highlights something really
important well two things
maybe three things it introduced us to
new weird people including weak
right-handed strong left-handed and that
guy from my hero academia who i have no
idea why they're joining us but we
clearly need to know their faces for
some reason
so let's bear them in mind this is a
note from future chantel
phantom phantom troop yeah okay i get it
thanks got it got it oh
another reason the moment was
narratively important god showed a
little pity for the people he was
grifting
it's funny because it's something my
sister and i used to do she's a very
tall woman and always has been even when
she was a child she was a tall woman we
went to a fair when she was eight and
asked them to guess her age in exchange
for prizes they thought she was 14.
it was wild because that was closer to
my age than hers at the time
and so we won many a prize anyway gone
showing pity and breaking out in a cold
sweat was an interesting moment it's
really stressful for people with low
empathy to maintain it
which suggests gone was actively feeling
the empathy and choosing to try to feel
that empathy
which is so interesting another thing if
it will take them that long to get
enough money to go into that concert
hall auction house that means something
else will happen to get them in
because it has to or they won't get in
and the whole point of this arc is for
something to go down at that very
specific location right
once we'd left gone quilo and leorio the
jumping around began in earnest but at
least frame
sat with us so we could get a little
more of an emotional connection between
them i really appreciated the insight
into characters
seeing how they move and the mood and
the music that accompanies them is what
gives me context as to who they are
and what part they might play last
episode i struggled with that this
episode i got exactly what i needed in
frame length and direction to really
hone in on the important figures of each
group
my love was here does he want to kill
the head of the phantom trope
what's going on here there's something
so intense happening because of course
it would be with hisoka but i don't
understand what
it is and it's not a trope he's not a
trope oh he's a trope i'm sorry he
really is
i also don't understand why neon would
be so desperate to attend an auction in
person oh well i guess we'll find out
her dad's coming personally to fix
things so sure let's up the stakes of
the entire
situation even more finally melody
melody a music hunter that's so cool i
loved that we didn't see her injury
i love that she hears the melody of his
heart what did she play she heard music
but does she play it the problem is
that now i'm wary liam warned me that
there are no good or pure characters in
this series but
melody seems like someone who could be
she just wants to take something
dangerous out of the world for goodness
sake why do i suspect that there are
going to be a lot of people hearing the
dark sonata
maybe it'll be part of greed island it
says a lot about what kuropika thinks of
her that he's told her he's a curta and
we're in contact
even if she knew he was willing to kill
her the two of them seem to be becoming
friends
or not friends but allies she sees
something in him and he's beginning to
see that she's different
she could be absolutely playing the long
game but even if she is
there's something really charming in
their frank and honest discussion
and all of this sat on the backdrop of
the flute possibly the flute solo she
heard that destroyed her body
it's a heartbreaking story that she has
and her reasoning is closer to karapika
than he probably expected and the art
style shifting to a hugely abstract one
was incredible because
because we couldn't imagine the softly
spoken sweet melody to be associated
with that broad stroke
harsh style i'm really looking forward
to learning more about her
episode 43 well the long discussion
about how important everyone in the
auction house was
i mean i literally wrote a note saying
it was the calm before the storm then a
guy turned up with guns for fingers
i appreciate the names for these powers
by the way the ambidextrous double
machine gun is indeed fearsome
and cute all at once you know something
i can say about this episode is that i'm
not the only one who was confused by
everything that was happening
all the characters were too and that's
great because i don't feel left out
anymore
in fact every single character was
except hisoka and the main
phantom troopy guy he seemed capable of
pulling everything together fairly
easily
goodbye to all those characters we saw
that i didn't learn the names to
properly
huzzah we still get haiku but no more
kisses or
you know busy which honestly it's hard
to see as a bad thing
we say goodbye to weird sideburn guy and
i don't even remember who the other one
was we never really needed to know who
he was so that was fine
tosino torchino
the sideburns didn't save you you were
dead before you realized you were which
reminds me of that other anime either
the one where people explode after a
punch
not one punch man though that's a though
that is a thing that other one
yeah the the old one that one see i know
anime anyway
sideburn guy that looks like eyebrow guy
is dead which is sad but not entirely
unexpected it's just a few episodes
later than i expected it to happen busy
though
her death came as a surprise not least
because it's a really sucky way to go
being smacked over their head by a
vacuum cleaner with a
mouth hang on sucky that pun was
unintended but i'm going to take it it's
mine now
the fact that we shifted to the purple
world of slow motion and silence was
beautiful because we saw bez's mind
empty as she tried to get away
and shizuku's mind empty as she focused
on the task at hand
we dropped the text and let the visual
speak for itself speaking of visuals
we've now had the nerdy woman with the
bees the breasty hardcore woman jumping
off cliffs the housewife the woman of
colour in servitude younger than she
should be and the traumatized and
dramatically
ugly but sweet on the inside woman oh
and we've got punk woman back at the
hunter
contract place oh and the tantra beat
teenager i love a good stereotype me i
truly do but i'm ready for a regular
female cast member
actually you know phantom troop healing
woman is pretty cool kind of badass
kinda does her own thing tell me more
about her she doesn't seem to enjoy the
stereotypes you've been placed in at
least as a healer feminist hour aside
i've
agreed with really big gun finger man
they were all
dead so easily and so fast there was so
much of the auction based entirely on
trust between thieves and yet not at all
about trust between thieves because one
of the shadow beasts came and removed
everything from the vault
i'm not sure what to make of the
situation at the moment there are a lot
of double crosses double crossing more
double crosses which is very odd
question was hunter hunter paid to
advertise iphone because everything is
iphones despite the screen of an iphone
going dark when you hold it to your ear
true story
sorry as to get distracting now so i had
to call it out he saw kadaling
ayo treta what's exactly going on why
wasn't hisoka anywhere on the scene is
he
trying to help krapika is he trying to
make things worse why didn't he get
involved and why was their leader just
watching him the whole time while they
talked
hisoka seems to have more power over
this situation than he should have and i
don't know what's going on but at least
i know that i don't know what's going on
i apologize for jumping around i jump
because there are so many things to jump
from and two
who are these ten dons were they there
that night
were they shot as are there shadow
beasts
please no more silhouettes it's becoming
a really frustrating mechanic to
introduce us to new characters
especially when they then turn up at the
end of the episode i understand that
should make things
easier but introduce a series of
silhouettes to a child who grew up
trying to guess which pokemon fits that
shape
and i can't look at silhouettes without
questioning who might be who
it's really hard being me do you think
random dude do you really think it might
be possible on some planet that we're
not
dealing with ordinary thugs they just
walked into a fully armed and protected
space with big bosses and a huge
quantity of power not only that but they
left the room pitted with bullets but no
evidence
oh i sigh you don't need nen or renin
to be better than random dude be better
than random dude everyone
these last scenes had so much
testosterone and suit material
everything got very graphically violent
very quickly and while i don't
really care i don't feel like enough has
changed from the hunter exam to now
to warrant the sudden shift in artistic
violence i don't
mind it really it just it doesn't change
whether i watch it's just such an
odd shift maybe it's to show that we're
in the real world now but
yeah it's such a stylistic change that i
wonder at this point whether they
changed art director or something in the
series as we were exposed to hunter
hunter's
answer to wolverine and those aliens
aliens
aliens we ended the episode with
pointing out just how much could arpican
melody have to learn
melody only sensed one heartbeat which
either means the others don't have
heartbeats or they're so
powerful melody couldn't sense them or
they materialized as they turned up
in any of those cases our kids are kids
really it's nice to see where they're
going and you know what
now i'm going to make liam feed me
because i'm hungry so that's it from me
i'm getting angry because i'm hungry i'm
hangry if you enjoyed this episode
click that thing that thing or that
thing you better click this thing
i'm sure there are a lot of things on
screen that you can click it's fun
clicking things so click things now
i'm hungry liam please feed me